are you ashamed Steen on the head of the  IFB division at how was a bonsai manager  spawn semen for criminals being Tana was  a bit tense the beginning first by the  end of it no I enjoyed it I think the  whole thing so I feel really enjoyable  but a lot of anyone from us beginning of  their career to that that's why their  career like business owner succession  everything between I've always yeah  really cool it's quite nice to spend  time with people though I'm I similar  journey to you I think we spoke about  it's a lot of the event but there's a  lot of bad stigma in recruitment and I  felt like the event itself actually  you've made it quite obvious so not  everyone in recruitment bad people yeah  everyone's bouncing ideas to each other  helping each other out  I think it's bit of like a comfort  blanket as well to know that you're not  doing that bad and there are people are  there two of you I think it's important  spending time with like-minded people  [Music]  you